brad pitt has been granted joint custody
of his five minor children with angelina
jolie
the news comes after a years-long legal
battle between the former couple
who share 19 year old maddox 17 year old
pax
16 year old fourteen-year-old shiloh and
twelve-year-old twins
vivian and knox you know i think about
everything i do now my kids are gonna
see when they grow up and how are they
gonna feel but they
they know me as a dad now a source tells
et
brad is incredibly happy adding quote
all brad ever wanted was to have joint
custody of his children
and he is relieved that the court ruled
in his favor
this is a huge deal given the prior
arrangement with the children
brad can't wait to spend more time with
them et has learned that the judge
issued a detailed
tentative ruling which found that
angelina's testimony lacked credibility
in many important areas
and that the existing custody order must
be modified in the best interest of the
children
angie who sought a divorce from brad in
2016
initially wanted primary custody while
brad requested
joint custody peter harvey a lawyer for
angelina who is close to the case but
not directly involved
told the associated press that the
actress supports joint custody
but added that the situation is
complicated and he can't go into detail
because the court proceedings are still
under seal
the news comes shortly after angie in a
monday court filing
obtained by e.t said that she would
appeal such a decision from the judge
whom she previously requested be removed
from the case
that request was denied in november and
in angelina's monday filing
she criticized the judge claiming he
denied her quote
a fair trial improperly excluding her
evidence relevant to the children's
health
safety and welfare evidence critical to
making her case
the actress also claimed the judge has
failed to adequately consider
a section of the california court's code
which says
it is detrimental to the best interest
of the child if custody is awarded to a
person with a history of domestic
violence per the docks from the register
i believe that angelina jolie is seeking
custody orders
and in support of those custody orders
she's alleging domestic violence
in a march court filing angelina claimed
to have proof of alleged domestic
violence against brad
at the time eti spoke to kelly chang
rickard a certified family law
specialist
who broke it all down domestic violence
is a serious charge in family law
so many people who use this are trying
to seek
sole custody brad was cleared of
allegations of child abuse by both the
fbi and the department of child and
family services back in 2016.
a source at the time told et brad was
heartbroken by the claim
he just wants to spend time with his
children and move in a positive
direction
his priority has always been his
relationship with his children
in the docs from angelina's most recent
filing
the actress claims the judge quote
refused to hear the minor teenager's
input
as to their experiences needs or wishes
as to their custody fate
in response to angelina's filing brad's
lawyers in docs obtained by et
said quote the judge has conducted an
extensive proceeding over the past six
months in a thorough fair manner
and reached a tentative ruling and order
after hearing from experts and
percipient
witnesses brad's own filing claimed that
the judge found angelina's testimony
quote
lacked credibility in many important
areas and the existing custody order
between the parties must be modified per
mr pitts request
in the best interests of the children et
has reached out to both brad
and angelina's lawyers for comment
you